zurück bei bild live mit einem
verhängnisvollen abend mega star johnny
depp soll amber heard verprügelt haben
die polizei als und penthouse in los
angeles und jetzt jetzt sagen die
beamten vor gericht aus im mega prozess
der beiden stars sich gegenseitig gewalt
und missbrauch vorwerfen
es wird gelacht eigentlich unvorstellbar
in diesem promi skandal prozess des
jahres
amber heard versus johnny depp es geht
um den vorwurf der häuslichen gewalt auf
embers seite und ihre anwältin feiert
ordentlich gegen johnny depp diese drei
tage hinaus teilen die waren entsetzlich
er hatte die kleider herunter gerissen
hat sie gegen die theke gepresster hatte
auf sie mit flaschen geworfen
er hat sie am boden geschlafen auf den
zerbrochenen gläserne er hat hat auf sie
eingeschlagen
er hat gesagt dass er sie hasst er
prügelte auf sie ein und dann drängen
mit einer schnapsflasche
auf der anderen seite johnny depp und
seine abgeschnittene fingerkuppe sein
anwalt will johnny depps unschuld
beweisen indem sie sich entschlossen hat
über ihren ehemann zum eigenen vorteil
zu lösen hat amber heard das leben von
herrn depp und seinen ruf auf ewig
verändert und geschädigt und sie werden
hören wie er ihnen erzählt welchen
schrecklichen auswirkungen herr
ausgesetzt waren
gestern wurden dann die aussagen der
polizisten im gericht gehört die in die
wohnung gerufen wurden und hier zeichnet
sich vor allem ein bild und zwar nicht
das von häuslicher gewalt
während ihrer untersuchung hatten sie
andere gründe zu glauben was wahr ist
das war eine verbale auseinandersetzung
und was haben sie bei den ermittlungen
festgestellt dass ihrer meinung nach
darauf hindeutet dass es sich nur um
einen verbalen streit gehandelt hat
nachdem ich die untersuchung mit meinen
partnern besprochen hatte und es ist
hart lehnte jede medizinische behandlung
ab und hatte keine sichtbaren
verletzungen
es gab keine anzeichen eines kampfes und
das opfer bzw
entschuldigung der zeuge mit dem ich
gesprochen habe war nicht kooperatives
november war mit freunden in der wohnung
als die polizisten kam
und wussten sie zu der zeitwert johnny
depp ist ja nun waren sie entfernen ich
glaube ich habe ein paar seiner filme
blockiert ich hatte es nicht so
eigentlich ihn zu sehen oder so
ich kann mich nicht an den letzten film
erinnern den ich von ihm
[Musik]
neben diesen polizisten
gesprochen habe was sie etwa drei meter
von mir entfernt sie war direkt vor mir
ich kann mich nicht erinnern dass ich
irgendwelche flecken blaue flecken oder
sonst etwas gesehen habe aber sie wissen
auch nicht ob sie make up getragen hat
um das zu überschminken nein nein
vielleicht trug sie make up um es zu
verbergen ja das kann schon sein man
kann wahrscheinlich alle blauen flecken
abdecken aber nicht das gestohlene
dachten dass jemand versucht in japan
und einzubrechen ich habe gesagt glauben
sie wirklich dass man versucht in ihre
wohnung einzudringen das war der hund
der versucht hat in die wohnung zu
kommen aber sie hatten solche angst
jemand versucht in meinem garten zu
kommen und ich dachte so auch wirklich
und sie baten mich jedes zimmer zur
überprüfung im sicher zu gehen dass
niemand da war und auch in das video vom
polizeieinsatz mit geschaut dezember mit
ihren freunden zu sehen und sie wird
gefragt ob alles okay sei sie antwortet
alles gut johnny seit zwei stunden nicht
mehr in der wohnung also wir dürfen
gespannt sein wie dieser prozess
weitergeht
total gespannt ist es völlig egal ob ot
dort aus dem auto das gericht so
geschaltet und macht er seine aussage
braucht in kreuth auch noch dabei und
kann sie über völlig überraschender
weise an nicht so immer nimmt das
richtig das ganze thema sein würzen